today on the matt walsh show the baby
killers are in a state of full-on panic
as the supreme court reportedly prepares
to overturn roe abolishing the
constitutional right to abortion which
was always fictional and never really
existed anyway
i have a lot to say about this as you
can imagine also an msnbc analyst warns
that nazis will take over because elon
musk owns twitter jen posaki makes the
lamest attempt yet to justify the biden
administration's new ministry of truth
the ruling class once again celebrates
itself at the met gala and in our daily
cancellation we'll discuss the story of
a woman who left her husband after she
met her true quote soul mate not a great
decision as it turns out we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
matte wall
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
show you know interest rates are
continuing to fluctuate they're very
volatile i really can't stress this
enough it's important to get ahead of
them and look into a mortgage refinance
while you can or better yet you should
pay off high interest debt while you
still can i mean you still have time to
save up to a thousand dollars a month
you just have to call american financing
america's home loan for a home for home
loans i should say or you'll get a free
mortgage review from a salary based
consultant there's no pressure with no
obligation no upfront or hidden fees
just a simple conversation around custom
loans that may fit your budget better
from flexible terms to accessing cash
and even debt consolidation it really
could mean up to a thousand dollars in
monthly savings plus tens of thousands
long term and if you start soon you
could close in as fast as 10 days so
this means that it's uh it's a quick
close it's very easy you're saving money
and that's something we could all use
more of i think uh these days so it's
really as simple as that and if you want
to go to american financing all you have
to do is call 866
569-4711 that's
forty 866-569-4700 eleven or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls one eight two
three three four nmlsconsumeraccess.org
roe v wade is not yet officially
overturned but it would appear that it's
on its last legs after killing so many
innocent lives row itself is now a dead
man walking condemned in its case justly
the earth-shattering news came last
night in a leaked draft of the 5-4
majority opinion written by justice
samuel alito roe is totally eviscerated
and repudiated um the subsequent 1992
decision planned parenthood versus casey
which rests on the foundation of roe
would also be overturned now the
political report which first published
the leaked draft calls it a
full-throated unflinching repudiation of
the very idea that the constitution
guarantees abortion rights which is
exactly what it is alito writes that
quote it's time to heed the constitution
and return the issue of abortion to the
people's elected representatives the
constitution does not prohibit the
citizens of each state from regulating
or prohibiting abortion row and casey uh
irrigated that authority we now overrule
this decision and return that authority
to the people and their elected
representatives the full text of the
opinion which runs some 98 pages is
available to be read
and it should be read because it's
almost certainly authentic and it
totally rips to shreds the legal
justifications and arguments for row
such as they are though really it
doesn't take 98 pages to accomplish that
task you only need about paragraph
because there is no legal reasoning
behind row
all you have to do is dig one inch below
the surface and you'll find that the
entire precipice of abortion rights
quote unquote is grounded in nothing it
has no roots
it would be a compliment to call it
flimsy at least flimsy things exist but
the constitutional right to abortion
does not exist
the activist judges who invented the
right attached it to
the constitutional right to privacy
which also does not exist in the
constitution there are then at least two
degrees of separation between abortion
rights and the actual text of the
constitution
that's how utterly baseless the decision
was and it's why it deserves to be
overturned
it is the worst supreme court decision
in history there are others that come
close
this is the worst
but uh roe is not yet overturned not yet
anyway that won't happen until the
decision is officially announced and
that brings us to the other major aspect
of this story the fact that it was
leaked in the first place
the whole point of leaking it
which is an unprecedented move nothing
like this has ever happened before in
american history the whole point of
course is to pressure one of the
justices and the majority to switch
sides the other reason behind the leak
is to push democrats in congress to pass
a bill heading the supreme court off at
the pass and codifying abortion rights
into law nationwide within minutes of
the politico piece being published the
democrat party had its messaging out and
it was calling for exactly that
just a few examples bernie sanders
tweeted congress must pass legislation
that codifies roe v wade as the law of
the land in this country now and if
there aren't 60 votes in the senate to
do it and there are not we must end the
filibuster to pass it with 50 votes
elizabeth warren said an extremist
supreme court is poised to overturn roe
v wade and impose its far-right
unpopular views on the entire country
it's time for the millions who support
the constitution and abortion rights to
stand up and make their voices heard
we're not going back not ever
ayanna bres ayanna presley said abortion
care is a fundamental human right and we
must legislate like it
aoc said people elected democrats
precisely so we could lead in perilous
moments like this to codify row hold
corruption accountable and have a
president who uses his legal authority
to break through congressional gridlock
on items from student debt to climate
it's high time we do it
and then nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
issued a joint statement calling the
reported decision
an abomination and one of the worst and
most damaging decisions in modern
history
meanwhile the fundraising emails have
already gone out
so the democrats were ready for this
which makes it look all the more like
the leak was coordinated at the highest
levels of the party all the evidence is
pointing in that direction and that
brings us to i think a few points that
um
need to be made here
first
leaking the full draft of a supreme
court decision in order to intimidate
justices and to put into switching sides
potentially putting their lives in
jeopardy in the process that's part of
the point of leaking it and also to
galvanize political support for your own
side
all of that
is much more of an assault on our
institutions and our democracy than
anything that happened on january 6th
may 2nd okay is the day the draft was
published that's yesterday that should
be the date that lives in infamy that's
what we should be talking about may 2nd
where were you on may 2nd
because that's um an actual insurrection
in effect it's an attempt to completely
upend and delegitimize the rule of law
incite violence and chaos and
potentially plunge the nation into civil
war
that's the whole intention behind it
january 6th was a stroll in the park
compared to this
it's not even close
leftists are cheering whoever leaked
this and will make that person into a
hero whenever their identity is unveiled
because when it comes down to it of
course
they couldn't care less about saving
democracy or protecting our institutions
they'll tear the whole thing down if it
benefits them
they won't even hesitate
second point speaking of democracy
if roe is overturned
um it will not have the effect of
abolishing abortion nationwide
you know the left likes to cite and
they're doing this a lot this morning
talking about um the polling data from
gallup and other
uh places which shows allegedly that 70
of americans oppose overturning roe
but that's only because most americans
don't understand what rho is and what
overturning it actually means and that's
because they're being lied to on this
point
all that will happen now
is the decision reverts back to the
states
which means that most of the leftists
hysterically hyperventilating right now
actually won't be affected at all by
this
their states will still have abortion
in fact
a lot of these states like in california
and new york and others they'll probably
have more abortions now
they're going to change the law to make
it even more
um accepting of abortion if it's
possible to make you know in a lot of
these cases they already have abortion
until birth
so how could you make the law more
radical well they're going to try
post birth abortions on the horizon
potentially
but just think about this the people who
claim to cherish democracy are now
panicking
because voters will get to decide on
abortion
they cherish democracy
and they're panicked because voters are
going to decide on abortion allowing
voters to decide the issue is now itself
an attack on democracy
according to the democracy advocates in
the democratic party
now i should say that in my case
um
i don't claim that democracy is my
highest value or priority that's what
they say
i think there are things higher and more
important than that which is why
overturning roe
is a great and necessary first step
and something to uh to certainly
celebrate
but it's only a first step as far as i'm
concerned the next step is to abolish
abortion and criminalize it nationwide
the next step is to essentially do what
idiot leftists think is already
happening
they think that overturning roe v wade
means that abortion is abolished nation
why that's not what it means
but um that's what they're worried about
and that's actually what we should try
to do
as always with the left i take a um you
know i'll give you something to cry
about approach with the left you're
gonna cry about it then you know i'll
give you something to cry about let's go
ahead and
criminalize it nationwide
and that is the next fight and
republicans have to lean into it
because the die is cast
the greatest cultural battle of our
lives doesn't end now it begins
democrats are going to do everything in
their power
and everything not in their power
to usurp the supreme court decision and
ensure that babies continue to die at
the same rate or at a higher rate than
before
republicans must respond not by
declaring victory and then just washing
their hands of the issue
uh not by hiding from it but by pushing
back in the other direction
they the democrats want to codify
abortion nationwide
we have to push to criminalize it
there's no escaping the fight now
you're either with us or against us on
this
and that goes for every elected
republican
third point bringing this all together
um as i have warned for years
the left in america is nothing less and
nothing more than a death cult
they fear death certainly fear it for
themselves anyway as evidenced by their
hysteria over covet but
paradoxically they worship destruction
they hate what is good and beautiful
they hate innocents most especially
they wish to destroy it all
that's why they spend so much of their
demonic energy preying upon children
they consider it their right to corrupt
abuse mutilate drug castrate and
sexualize children outside of the womb
inside the womb they believe it's their
sacred right to butcher and dismember
the most precious and vulnerable of
god's creation
believe that this is literally sacred
as the democrat lieutenant governor of
pennsylvania put it last night
he tweeted let's be clear
the right to an abortion is sacred
democrats have to act quickly get rid of
the filibuster to pass the women's
health protection act and finally codify
roe into law we cannot afford to wait
sacred he says
and he means it
they all mean it
why is abortion sacred to them why is it
their highest sacrament why does it
attract the most
religious zeal from the death worshipers
because abortion
is the ultimate middle finger to
objective morality to truth
to nature to the family
to god
to everything they despise
through abortion a woman declares that
she lives for herself and for herself
alone
she sacrifices her child her family
her femininity
everything on the altar of her own ego
the altar of the self
she fully initiates herself into the
cult of self-worship
abortion is in many ways like satan's
parody of baptism
the woman baptizes herself in the blood
of her own child and becomes a fully
liberated fully realized independent
person i mean that's the dogma anyway
that's the faith-based claim of course
in reality through abortion the woman
destroys herself
consigns herself to despair
and loneliness and grief
but they don't tell her that
they make very different promises
and they cannot let abortion go without
surrendering their entire world view
abortion is
the foundation of everything they've
built
or i should say it's the foundation of
everything they've torn down
because they don't build they just tear
things down it lies at the center of
everything for them
and so they'll fight like rabid dogs to
protect it
they will do anything i mean literally
anything lie cheat steal kill
anything
so be it
this is a fight worth having no matter
the cost
and i'm telling you right now it's about
to get very very ugly
so buckle up
and get ready
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well
it's finally happened the fed is
realizing the dire straits our economy
is in thanks to our loose monetary
policy apparently you can't just spend
trillions every year with no
repercussions turns out i mean who who
would have thought
aside from any rational person now to
play ketchup the fed has been raising
rates and plans to plans uh to raise
them seven times this year alone you're
already starting to see those ripple
effects in the housing market as
people's buying power diminishes to
consider what could happen in the stock
market if our economy stalls out don't
wait till that happens take some of your
profits from the stock market now and
solidify them with gold from birch gold
throughout history gold has maintained
its value better than any other
investment in the world text walsh to 98
98 98 for a free zero obligation info
kit on holding gold in a tax sheltered
retirement account join the thousands of
happy birch gold customers with
countless five star reviews and an a
plus rating with the better business
bureau i trust the professionals at
birch gold you should too text walsh to
98 98 98 and secure the gains you've
made while you can
you know on a lighter note before i get
back into the heavy stuff i forgot to uh
yesterday i forgot to give a shout out
to the sweet baby gang member who
represented the gang at my kid's first
communion on saturday um
and it was it was it was after mass for
the record but
somebody shouted sweet baby gang
you know as we were walking to like the
reception and um and i appreciated that
there's never an inappropriate time to
rep the gang now my wife
i should tell you
doesn't really agree with me on this
point but i think there's never an
inappropriate time i mean if you see me
graveside
at a funeral ceremony
there would be nothing wrong with
shouting sweet baby gang
if if i'm in the hospital dying of some
horrific illness and you happen to be
walking by in the hallway and you see me
in there nothing wrong with poking your
head in and saying sweet baby gang in
fact i would really appreciate it that's
the last thing i heard before i died
so
um
another shout out to the uh
remember the sweet baby the loyal member
of the sweet baby gang
at the first communion okay more on the
top story of the day and of the of the
century really first of all i got to
play this because libs of tick tock is
uh as always johnny on the spot with the
compilation of leftists melting down
over um
the draft decision and the possibility
that roe v wade will be overturned
and there's gonna be a lot more where
this came from
but here's just the the first round and
it's quite enjoyable so let's watch
[Music]
this abortion law goes beyond a woman's
issue and it goes beyond anything you
can ever imagine the societal
implications of this are gonna be insane
the amount of uh just
pain and damage this is gonna cause and
the full ability to tell a woman what
she can and can't do with her body and
we're going back into a handmaid's tale
society here all of you women
who sat home
all you young
girls adults over 18 years old who did
not go out and vote
who did not think that you need to
protect
your womb
we're now back in the dark ages um brace
yourselves ladies
i'm with you
my heart is just
broken
i don't understand why this country
hates women so much
i just don't understand it
we'll get through this we'll figure out
a way
no more joking about
it being
a handmaid's tale it will be
you know a couple of things there um
first of all there really is something i
think
and you can't judge a book by its cover
all the time
but i think there is something about the
ugliness
of leftism
that seems to manifest itself
in a physical way
as well
you know if you
buy into the the leftist death cult
you become a very ugly person on the
inside and and it's just interesting
that so often
that tends to reflect
um
on the outside as well which which you
see so often we saw we saw there
um
and of course
a couple other takeaways is that these
people have only read one book handmade
stale which i'm not even sure that
they've read that book they've probably
just seen the show and maybe they
haven't even seen the show they're just
aware of it and so that's the only it's
it used to be harry potter but we got to
get rid of harry potter because uh jk
rowling is transphobic apparently and so
now it's handmade still and speaking of
transphobia
i have to say that i am
totally shocked and scandalized by the
transphobia on display from the left
since last night
do you notice how all i mean i don't
know what happened but but uh all of a
sudden at least for this news cycle
women are female again
because we keep hearing how this is an
attack on women
and it's like these people don't realize
that men can get pregnant or at least i
thought they could that's why isn't that
what you've been telling us
so you'll just see how just for the news
cycle just for this issue not even just
the news cycle but for this particular
issue right now
um women are
defined biologically
because that's what they need right now
and then you move on to the next topic
and they don't need that anymore so
they'll throw that to the side
this is the this is the um advantage of
being a relativist though
that you can invent whatever truth you
need whatever truth you want in whatever
situation and so for this this is an
attack on women's rights
even though and the other thing we keep
hearing now is that um
you know this men men are legislating
women's bodies and putting aside how
again the fact that that statement
contradicts everything they say about
sex and gender but also
actually it was seven white men it was
seven old white men who decided row
and now it's looking like that decision
is going to be overturned by a group
that includes a woman and a black man
so diversity is our strength this is a
win
this is a win for diversity in fact it's
one of the only wins for diversity that
we've seen in quite some time
um meanwhile over on cable news they've
brought in jeffrey tubin
public masturbator to give his thoughts
on um on all of this because he's their
legal analyst and uh here's what he had
to say you know there is a lot of
evidence
there are many societies especially in
central and south america that ban
abortion altogether
and the rate of abortion does not go
down
when when abortion is banned there are
just as many abortions if not more in
societies where abortion is legal what's
different is that women die
and women are horribly mutilated uh
because abortion is is
conducted in a uh unsafe way but the
idea of a legal ban on abortion stopping
abortion is a myth it does not have all
it does is drive the process underground
and
endanger women's lives
now jeffrey toobin is you you may think
uh why they're bringing this guy on to
talk about this issue but he
is really invested in the abortion issue
because he cheated on his wife and um
conceived a child with his mistress and
then paid for his mistress to uh to have
an abortion demanded that his mistress
have an abortion
so he's very invested and he's an expert
in that way you know he has he has some
lived experience with this issue
and you're always going to find that
with the men who feel the strongest
about keeping abortion legal it's
because they've got very self-serving
reasons for that
as i've tried to explain before
this is one thing that women should
understand i think i think every
pro-life woman does
but pro-abortion women don't and that is
that
the men who are your quote allies
it's only because they want to use you
well there are two reasons
uh one is it's a virtue signal on their
part
and but but i think at a deeper level
it's because they want to use you like
an object they want to be able to use
you sexually
and then just throw you aside and not
have any consequences not have any
responsibilities or obligations that
come with it that's what that's about
that's why they're your ally
because you are a sexual object you are
nothing but a glorified masturbatory aid
to them
and that's how they want to use you
and they are more than willing if it
means that they can
uh use you
for their own sexual gratification
um if that means that killing a child
they're perfectly fine with that
so those are your allies
ladies
and you notice as to the substance of
his argument such as it is he says two
things we're gonna hear a lot of this we
already have
uh one is that if you get rid of
abortion which again
overturning roe v wade does not get rid
of abortion
but if you do then it's going to make
abortion unsafe for women
and also getting rid of abortion will
not drive the rate of abortion down so
we heard both of those things
as for the unsafe part of this
well first of all there's no such thing
as a safe abortion
because in every abortion at least one
person is killed
uh unless the baby survives the abortion
and then is killed outside the womb or
left to die in the corner of a room
somewhere as
often happens as has happened in dc
recently
um
so that's that's what abortion is it is
by its nature inherently unsafe
it's also unsafe for women inherently by
its nature
it is physical destruction it is uh
in a culture where we call everything
violence abortion is violence and it's a
violent act
a violent lethal act being carried out
within your body
and that is by its nature unsafe
physically
never mind psychologically emotionally
and
spiritually where it's totally
devastating
but as to the the physical part of it
um
is is it true that um
it's probably physically quote safer
for a woman to get an abortion at a
clinic as opposed to in a back alley
somewhere
even though the back alley hysteria back
alley abortion hysteria is mostly mostly
based based on myths and everything else
but is it is it true that it's
most of the time going to be quote
physically safer for the woman to get
the abortion in a in a clinic as opposed
to the mythical back alley well yeah of
course
but
a a sane and civilized and moral society
which is grounded in law
should not provide safe spaces to kill
children
so if going into a back alley to get an
abortion means that it turns into this
dark and dirty and disgusting thing
well
yeah because that's what it is
and we shouldn't be doing anything to
sanitize it or make it safer
any more than we should be providing
an environment
for mothers to bring their two-year-olds
and have them euthanized
as far as this claim that it that
outlawing abortion doesn't drive the
rate of abortion down
i would not take that claim on face
value from jeffrey toobin in the first
place
but even just pretending that it's true
which it isn't
but pretending for a second for the sake
of argument that's true that you outlaw
abortion and it doesn't drive the rate
of abortion down like of course it does
but just again
for the sake of argument let's pretend
that's true
well it's basically irrelevant
i mean
murder in all forms
outside of the womb anyway murder in
every other form is
illegal and yet it still happens
like the fact that it's illegal to just
walk up to somebody and shoot them in
the head does that prevent people from
doing it obviously not go to any major
city in america and it happens all the
time
so the simple fact that murder is
illegal doesn't stop anyone in fact
nobody
is prevented from committing murder just
because it's illegal
the laws against um
against murder have almost no direct
preventative
effect
because you could still just walk up to
somebody and kill them if you want
same for the laws against rape same for
the laws against everything
you can still do it and all of these
things still happen
i mean human beings have been raping and
killing each other since the dawn of
human civilization tragically and that's
always going to be the case so does that
mean that you just get rid of the laws
against murder and rape because it's
going to happen anyway
no you still have the laws in place
because number one again if you're if
you want to be a civilized sane just
moral society
then you cannot tolerate and accept
actions like that
crimes like that
also you need to have something in place
to punish people who commit these acts
and to segregate those who have shown a
willingness to commit those acts from
the rest of society to keep everybody
safe
and there is certainly
we have to assume some deterrent effect
in having murder illegal
so the argument just doesn't make any
sense
whether it drives the rate of abortion
down or not uh the fact is you ha it
must be illegal because it's the murder
of a child and that's it
that's why it should be illegal
all right
you know the other great thing about
this decision the draft decision anyway
is that it completely ruined the night
for all of the libs at the met gala last
night um the met gala was was happening
with the theme gilded glamour
and uh they all showed up on the red
carpet so i want to go through
a little bit of a you don't expect
you're going to get this today but we're
going to do a little bit of a fashion
review let's just go through some of the
looks and first of all mayor eric adams
was there
and you know
he promised to put an end
to the violent crime epidemic in the
city lots of people were wondering
how he would do that
and last night he finally unveiled his
plan to get rid of gun violence and
there it is there he's wearing a suit
that says end gun violence
and just like that the violent crime
epidemic
in new york city and indeed across the
entire country was was brought to an end
because of eric adams so that i thought
was was pretty courageous lots of other
courageous let's just go through some of
these i don't even know what you're
gonna put up on the screen okay so we
got this person here i don't know who
that person i don't know who any of
these people are
but she's got that uh a little bit of um
if you i think it's a beautiful dress if
you want to look like a diseased bird
or maybe a pin cushion it's a great look
go to the next one what else do we have
here another so it's more of the
diseased bird look
okay now this this i like this right
here because this is kind of that um
if you're going for the pepto-bismol
vibe
and that vibe is really in right now so
i don't know who that is but it's a guy
with a full pink suit pink shoes and
everything that's a great look i'm
actually liking all these
okay this guy that's just if you want to
look stupid i guess you wear that we can
go to the next one
okay this one right here
that's the one this is like
if
edward scissorhands
had sex with a peacock
and then the kid grew up
and became addicted to meth
and was a sex offender that's what it
would look like all right i think we saw
enough there
and all of those people oh then there's
that one too there that's kind of like
if you get a bdsm outfit at party city
that's what you would i think that's
probably what that would look like all
those people they got dressed up they
got they spent thousands of dollars on
their on their nice outfits and they
went into the gala the banquet and it's
right then that the news dropped
that roe v wade was was is going to be
overturned and i just i love every part
of that
um even if the news never should have
been leaked in the first place
okay
let's uh move to this msnbc uh the
anchor over at msnbc worries that nazis
may be taking over because of elon musk
taking control of twitter i'm not sure i
exactly see the connection but let's
listen to him make the case anyway i
mean it's easy in american discourse to
talk simplistically about the far left
and the far right as two equally
dangerous fringe blocks elon musk has
done it plenty of times just in the past
week
but here's the difference america's far
left wants to give us free health care
and free child care america's far right
wants to give us white supremacy and no
democracy
and this asymmetrical polarization of
u.s politics would be laughable if it
weren't so horrifying we are living
through an unspeakably dangerous moment
the pro-q anon pro-neo-nazi faction of
the republican party is poised to expand
dramatically come the midterms
we're just two years away from donald
trump very possibly re-seizing executive
power if that happens we may look back
on this past week as a pivotal moment
when a petulant and not so bright
billionaire casually bought one of the
world's most influential messaging
machines
and just handed it to the far right
uh a not so bright billionaire says the
talking head on msnbc not so bright i
mean the guy is the richest man in the
world and he builds rockets
and he's he's not he just builds rockets
and he's planning to go to mars
okay elon musk is actually going to
to land
crafts on mars
but he's not so bright he's certainly
not as bright as a bloviating talking
ahead on msnbc
and uh this guy whoever he is he says
that uh you know the far left and the
far right can't be compared
they're not equally as dangerous and
he's right about that part but he's
wrong about all the rest of it
all the far left wants to do is give you
free health care yeah that's all they
want to do uh what he forgets to mention
is that the free health care that the
far left wants to give
includes
dismembering babies in the womb and
chemically castrating 12 year old boys
that's the health care so he forgot to
he left that part out he forgot about
that part
but otherwise again i totally agree with
him that you can't compare the far right
and the far left this is something that
elon musk
does
you know because elon musk himself
despite how he is portrayed
is not a member of the far right
i'm not sure you could really say he's a
member of the right at all
i don't know that he would identify
himself as a conservative and i don't
think i would identify him that way
but he said many times recently that he
considers the far right and the far left
to be a problem and
so he wants to handle twitter in a way
that you know if it upsets the the most
extreme ten percent of on both ends of
the spectrum that means you're doing
your job
um
and in spite of saying that of course
the the left is still freaking out about
him
because
musk is look is is trying to find an
avenue here of kind of neutrality
and the left does not want neutrality
they take it if you're with a you know
with us or against this approach
and they take that approach with
everything
and they take it with the issue of free
speech as well
but musk is wrong about that when he
when he says oh they're they're equally
as dangerous
no they're not
because on the far left again
you know that's where you get the death
cult
that's where you get people who
are right now panicking over the thought
that more babies will be born
that's what they're upset about
all right one of the club i want to play
for you jen pasaki yesterday at the
white house press conference was asked
about the disinformation board the
ministry of truth and here's her
explanation of it
the mandate is not to adjudicate what is
true or false online or or otherwise um
it will operate in a nonprofit partisan
in a political manner it's basically
meant to coordinate a lot of the ongoing
work that is happening and what their
focus is the focus is on disinformation
threatens the homeland as i noted which
things like inciting things that would
incite violent extremism
you know human traffickers and other
transnational criminal organizations uh
any efforts that poll malign foreign
influence anything that would endanger
individuals during emergencies so a lot
of this work is really about work that
people may not see every day that's
ongoing by the department of homeland
security
she says that it's nonpartisan which is
the same thing we heard from the dhs
secretary yesterday in his interview on
cnn where he said that the person who is
helming is going to be at the the lead
of the quote-unquote disinformation
board is totally neutral but once again
that we we know that that is not true
there's no such thing as a neutral
person especially not on the left really
not anywhere in human society not
anywhere in the human race nobody is
actually neutral everybody has a world
view a perspective
which is exactly why you cannot entrust
human beings in the government with
something like this
and you certainly
they claim that it's going to be
non-partisan
there is no
non-partisan part of the government
that may exist in theory that may be an
ideal that you
strive towards but that doesn't actually
exist
everybody in government all of them
have um political leanings political
uh
loyalties all of them don't
which is why you cannot entrust them
with something like this uh one other
thing here is from the daily wire it
says security guard travis mcgivern um
testified monday that he had to re he
had to remove johnny depp from a
situation due to the actor's ex-wife
amber heard physically assaulting him
hurd allegedly punched depp in the face
during the incident threw a can of red
bull at the actor and tried to spit on
him depp is suing the aquaman actress
for more than 50 million dollars over
alleged defamation stemming from an
op-ed heard penned at the washington
post claiming to be a victim of domestic
violence hurt his countersued for more
than 100 million dollars herself
giver and testified at some point i
witnessed miss heard through a red bull
can that struck mr depp in the back at
that point i moved closer mr depp i
didn't want my client to get hit with
anything else their verbal onslaught
continued from both of them
misheard through something else either a
purse or a bag and i was able to knock
it away so it didn't hit
depp at one point she spit at him
and a lot of verbal vitriol from both of
them
and then he says that he had to get
johnny depp out of the situation for his
own safety
now
this is the latest out of this trial and
um here's my my point about this
now i'm
it's good that it seems like most people
who have followed the trial between
amber heard and johnny depp
um
are realizing that this is not the the
simple picture that amber heard
and her advocates wanted to paint where
you know she's the the victimized woman
and he's the evil man and all that i
think most people are realizing that
it's it's more complicated than that
but then you have people that are going
too far to the other end of the spectrum
here and are coming fully to johnny
depp's defense and they're fully on his
side and amber hurd is the is the
villain here
no there are i
and i say this as someone i admit
haven't i haven't followed the case
the story that closely
but i just know because this is a
general principle that is almost always
true not always but almost always true
in a you know in a divorce situation
marriage falling apart something like
this
there is very rarely a clear good guy
and a clear bad guy
you know they both can recall situations
where one person was the good guy and
one one person was the bad guy
but that's the thing they both have
evidence of that they both have examples
they can present and then they're just
throwing those examples back and forth
and sometimes they're throwing physical
objects as well
because in the vast majority of cases
um it takes more than one person to make
a marriage fall apart
which is why it's
normally quite absurd to take sides
especially when it's celebrities it's
people you don't even know
even when it's a couple that you do know
taking sides when the marriage is
falling apart is usually a bad move
because it means you're getting you're
getting the story from one person and
they're just telling their side of it
and they're not going to tell you all
the terrible stuff that they've done
but when it's celebrities
like it's just it's guaranteed that
they're both total scumbags
johnny depp
has already been divorced multiple times
and uh and i do know this much about him
he left the mother of his children to go
shack up with this amber heard character
and then a year later the marriage fell
apart
marriage barely lasted a year so he left
his family for this woman and the
marriage falls apart
so that already means he cannot be the
the flat out good guy here which doesn't
make amber hurt a good person it just
means they're both bad guys
like it almost doesn't matter what
happened in this particular marriage you
left your family for this woman
you abandoned your kids
so you're already the bad guy there's no
recovering that
so and that just makes it a little bit
simpler uh they're both probably
scumbags and uh also by the way johnny
depp
if you're a conservative defending him
he almost certainly hates your guts and
would never come to your defense if he
ever if he if he cared enough to say
anything about you which you wouldn't so
another thing to keep in mind
you know using the internet without
expressvpn it's uh kind of like taking a
call on a train or a bus on speaker for
everyone to hear you don't know who has
asked who has access to your most
private sensitive information even
though lots of people actually seem
willing to do just that we'll even use
facetime in public which i find
incredibly annoying uh so don't be that
person here's why i use expressvpn
internet service providers know every
single website you visit and in the us
they can legally sell this information
to ad companies and tech giants who then
use your data to target you expressvpn
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
people can't peep on your online
activity just fire up the app click on
the button
it's as simple as that it works on
phones laptops even routers so everybody
who shares your wi-fi can be protected
no wonder it's rated number one by
business insider and the verge secure
your online activity today at
expressvpn.comwalsh get an extra three
months free of expressvpn that's
expressvpn
walsh again that's expressvpn.com
walsh let's get now to the comment
section
do you know their name
sharon says uh i'm so excited to have
johnny the walrus for my preschool class
the kids love the book when i was
reading it this morning they immediately
asked if i could read it again um i love
that i'm hearing people read it to
preschool classes people are
another great thing that you can do if
you want to be very charitable is you
know they have those um
a lot of a lot of places will have those
little free box libraries that you know
on the sidewalk and you could just put a
book in there
leave a book take a book type of thing
i'm hearing people leaving there you
know donating
boxes to schools and libraries all of
that is great and i appreciate it and
it's again charitable work as well
um
let's see wayne talking about the
discovery plus documentary about uh
called generation drag about
cross-dressing kids and their abusive
parents wayne says in some cases i can't
fault the parent in the documentary when
i was a father in the late 80s and early
90s and the boys became teens it was a
constant battle of wills we punished it
we punished but still it didn't uh stop
their rebelliousness when they were out
of sight it's tough teaching your
children the truth when they're
bombarded daily by lies today i think
the pressure is far worse than back then
for some of those fathers in the video
who don't agree i doubt they'd say
anything in the documentary i could
imagine what would happen if they did
the mothers or fathers that
would speak out wouldn't be on the show
and probably be demonized
well wayne i
appreciate your attempt to be charitable
to these parents but i think it's
vastly misguided in this case
you know
first of all
saving your children from something like
this
is
worth any cost you have to pay including
and especially being villainized by what
the mass media
by the left by the culture who cares
about that
i mean that's something if you're going
to be a parent at all
then you need to be willing to be
villainized
because that's the way the culture
responds to good parenting these days
and it's been that way for a long time
so i'm not gonna i don't accept that
excuse at all
and yeah it is very difficult to be a
parent i know that
and i think that there are
serious challenges that parents today
face
that parents in the past did not face
now there are serious challenges that
parents in the past
face that we don't but
they're just certain things we're
dealing with right now i mean let's just
take the the internet for one thing
social media all that sort of thing you
know if you uh were a parent
in the 90s or any time before that in
human history you didn't have to worry
about
this little
um
contraption that your kid might carry
around just totally overtaking their
entire life i mean i guess back in the
90s you had game boys or something like
that and maybe some kids play with those
too too much but uh just just now having
social media there's like this whole
other
universe that exists out there where
kids get sucked into it and it becomes
their entire life their entire identity
and uh it's where they're exposed to the
most hideous and graphic and
perverse things imaginable that's
something that didn't exist in the past
it does now so those are all the
challenges and i get that
but that's your calling that's what
you're called to that's your vocation
because you're a parent today you're not
a parent 30 years ago you're a parent
today
and so you just have to deal with that
and there's simply never a time when you
can as a parent
go along with
your kid destroying themselves
your kid rejecting their own
essential nature
your boy rejecting his masculinity
parading around on stage cross-dressing
being used as a pawn being sexualized
in that way i mean you can never accept
that
you got to fight tooth and nail every
day to save your child from that if
that's what it takes
all right um
let's see what else do we have here
cool papa j magic says the crusades were
based matt you should do a series about
the crusades and other history that's
told in falsehoods by the regime
yeah the thing about the crusades is
that they happen over the course of
centuries and it's hard to
speak in general terms about this entire
period of history that that ex that's
spanned centuries but one thing we can
say about the crusades and they don't
teach this in school because they don't
teach much of anything worth knowing in
school
but the crusades were launched as a
defensive strike
against
what at that point was centuries of
muslim aggression so that's the most
important thing to know about the
crusades
and finally andrew says matt why are you
not promoting your movie what is a woman
well stay tuned
very soon i'll have a lot more i just
i've i've been it's been like a gag
order there's so much i've wanted to say
about this film
and but but very soon you're gonna hear
a lot more about it and that's all i can
say right now just stay tuned
when the world goes woke the daily wire
builds alternatives that's why we
started our own publishing wing called
dw books and we're so proud to announce
that one of our first books fiery but
mostly peaceful the 2020 riots and the
gasoline of america is finally available
for purchase today the book is written
by julio rosas who exposes the black
lives matter riots that broke out across
the country in the aftermath of george
floyd's death and exposes them for the
sham that they all really were roses who
was reporting from the ground has as a
first-hand experience that he
illuminates the media's attempts to
convince americans that the fatal and
destructive riots were
peaceful somehow here check out the
trailer
the media gasoline the american people
for all of 2020 as the riots unfolded
they did not give you the full story
i was there george floyd kyle
rittenhouse ray shark books jazz in
seattle i saw all the riots with my own
eyes windshields being smashed giant
rocks that were being from businesses
that were starting to be looted the
crowd started to become hostile
all the cops were trapped and surrounded
police were being ordered to to retreat
i experienced the tear gas i experienced
the smoke this was very real to me
the mainstream media they were trying to
call them protests cnn with that chiron
saying fiery but mostly peaceful they're
trying to push a narrative of don't
believe your lying eyes because they
were trying to appease a very dedicated
antifa movement that's there we read my
book fiery but mostly peaceful you will
get the full story you will learn what
actually happened during the riots of
2020 and what the media did not want to
tell you buy my book fiery but mostly
peaceful everywhere books are sold
the book is available right now for
purchase on amazon or anywhere you go
buy books online so order your copy
today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
now an epic story with a twist ending
for our daily cancellation today begins
with the sydney morning herald and an
article by a woman named amanda
trenfield which is actually an excerpt
from a forthcoming book by the same
author
more on that book in just a moment
the title of the piece is less than a
month after i met my soul mate i ended
my 14-year marriage
now from here we're told all about
amanda's first encounter with her soul
mate and about the decision she made to
leave her husband in pursuit of this
other man she reports quote
i wasn't expecting a formal dinner with
cheerful conference attendees in the
beautiful west australian town of
margaret river to turn my life upside
down i had a good life i wasn't looking
to upend it or was i
i decided only the week earlier to
attend the three-day event with my
husband it wasn't in the family holiday
plan and we had to arrange care for the
children but i saw it as a perfect
opportunity for us to reconnect as we
had become quite distant i believe that
time away from the stress of everyday
life was the perfect remedy to reignite
our relationship
now it appears that she gave the
reconnecting with my husband and
reigniting our relationship idea about
30 minutes to pan out and when it didn't
she immediately started ogling another
man she tells us about how she fell
madly in love with a dude named jason
who was sitting at the same table as her
at this conference and she says they
talked all night
um she took sips from his glass of wine
he fed her dessert
and we're not we're not told where the
husband was during all this in fact
amanda's husband is not mentioned hardly
at all through the entire story her
children also are not mentioned after
the first paragraph
they're not even background characters
in amanda's love story they don't exist
which tells you everything you need to
know really
be that as it may wherever her husband
was during all this um here's a tip that
hopefully most men don't need to hear
but if your wife is sitting with another
man at a table
staring lovingly into his eyes
and eating pieces of chocolate cake off
of his fork
you may want to have a chat with her
because you've probably got some serious
problems
now later we're told that amanda and
jason went to the hotel hotel bar again
the husband is absent from the narrative
again i must remind any man listening
that it's a very bad sign if your wife
is sitting with
any man except for you at a hotel bar
but amanda tells us quote
at the hotel bar jason bought me a glass
of my favorite rose we looked into each
other's eyes his dark and mysterious
mind big and brown
and clinked glasses the electricity
between us was strong and raw it
traveled to my core
it was so intense i needed to break eye
contact the energy it was electric
my body was completely charged i was
completely on
i loved talking with him i felt warm
relaxed and safe in his presence i felt
i could truly be myself at a level i
wasn't familiar with
i realized that
it was a it was a feeling i hadn't
enjoyed in a long long time perhaps ever
the bar called last drinks and the
evening now the early morning came to an
end
the goodbye was overt
open and revealing of our mutual
affection
we enjoyed a body-hugging embrace where
i whispered into his ear this isn't over
i need to see you again he put his hands
tightly on my waist and pulled me close
yes he replied
it was all i needed to hear
um
and i just i keep going back the same
question where's the husband
she's locked in an embrace with a guy
whispering in his ear and her husband's
just off and somewhere else
well it looks fine nothing to worry
about there
now she says that this experience
flirting with jason at the hotel bar
profoundly changed her as she puts it i
knew in my heart in my soul in the very
fabric of my being that i had profoundly
changed i couldn't articulate the
feelings the sensations the experience
the connectedness i experienced with
jason was at a level impossible to
describe all i knew for certain was that
this one encounter in the most unlikely
of places under the most unusual
circumstances had dramatically altered
my life
actually there's nothing unusual about
the circumstances um i think
people having affairs at hotel bars
pretty common uh they left the
conference and went home amanda had no
more contact with the mysterious jason
but a month later she left her husband
ditched her kids tore her family apart
ended her marriage
and set out to be with the true love of
her life her true soul mate jason
and you can find out much more about
this story in her memoir soon to be
published titled
when a soul mate says no
because as it turns out her soul mate
jason rejected her i mean we can only
imagine that uh when the woman he
flirted with for a few hours at a bar a
month ago
showed up at his doorstep and announced
that she left her family for him
he was extremely creeped out
i'm not sure how he broke the news to
her but the end result
is that amanda was left alone rejected
and humiliated
she had ruined her life for nothing she
was a failure
uh an embarrassment
a woman whose unquenchable narcissism
had destroyed her family and now she has
nothing to show for it where could she
go from there
what could she do
well what else but become a life coach
yes amanda trenfield is now according to
her website
a transformational life coach
she's even certified in the field she's
a certified reinvention coach she claims
now i have no idea how one obtains a
certificate as a reinvention coach
but there's no question that amanda is
qualified after all she had a stable
life and a family and um and she
reinvented it into a pile of rubble
very similar to the way that i
reinvented my parents car when i was 19
by having a head-on collision
you know and nobody was injured in that
case in amanda's case entire lives were
destroyed and devastated
and now she wants to coach you on how to
do the same to your own life
so that's not exactly how she puts it of
course the description of her book tries
to put a positive spin on all this in
the description it says
amanda never imagined that after
uprooting her comfortable stable life to
make room for her soulmate that he would
decide to go his own way
they both agreed that their connection
was unbelievably cosmic
so why did he say no
a fearless voyage of self-discovery
fueled by stubbornness tenacity and an
unquenchable thirst for answers to the
great mysteries of the soul amanda
shares the intimate details of her
transformation from lovesick hot mess to
self-actualized superstar with
unapologetic vulnerability and
effervescent humor through the
exploration of grief spirituality energy
therapies self-acceptance and the
undeniable healing power of a good diana
raw song amanda's story serves as an
example of what is possible when we dare
to dream of a life that's nothing short
of miraculous
that is a very flowery way of putting i
screwed my whole life up
and her story does indeed serve as an
example it shows the possibilities that
open up when you shirk your
responsibilities reject your obligations
to your family and to your spouse and to
god break your promises betray your vows
blow your whole life to pieces for the
sake of fleeting emotional or sexual
enjoyment
and really all of those possibilities
are just one possibility which present
themselves in vaguely different forms
the possibility is that you which is
really a certainty is that you end up
alone pathetic and miserable and you
spend the rest of your life trying to
justify and rationalize the mistakes you
made and also attempting to recruit more
people to join you in your misery and
your failure
many many many such cases amanda is but
one
but there is another important lesson we
can learn from amanda um
and that is that this is one of the of
the dangers of the soulmate trope
of course the real cause of amanda's
troubles is not any misunderstanding
about souls or mates but
you know it's really her own
catastrophic narcissism cowardice and
weakness but even so it's important to
note that the soulmate
as the concept is presented in old
disney films and uh nicholas sparks
novels and so on
is a myth
there is not one single person who you
are destined to be with your romantic
match is not written in the stars
somewhere
and the problem with seeing things this
way
is that
if there's just one person in the world
made for you
then it's possible even likely if you
just do the numbers game
that whoever you marry is not that
person
it's possible in this way of thinking to
marry the wrong person
and it's also possible that you'll meet
the right person after having already
married the wrong one
well sorry honey i thought our marriage
was written in the stars turns out i
misread the stars it was actually
supposed to be my secretary so see you
later
again many such cases
so
am i saying that my own wife
is not my soul mate no i am not saying
that
she is my soul mate because we chose
each other and stood at the altar and
got married
now we are bonded together for life in a
deep and mysterious and spiritual way
now we are souls forged together as one
now we are soul mates
i think this is actually quite a bit
more romantic because it makes us active
participants in our own love stories
we weren't drawn together by destiny we
chose each other by our own free will
and we bestowed the sacrament of
marriage onto each other which is how
marriage works
so my wife didn't marry me because i was
her soul mate i'm her soul mate
because she married me
that's the truth and it's so much better
really than the half-baked nonsense you
get from amanda and the life coaching
community
but if you don't believe me and you want
to hear more from amanda and hear her
side of this you can always have a
one-hour consultation with her i went to
her website and checked it out it'll
cost you just about 400 an hour
and the good news is that i looked and
she has wide open availability every day
of every hour this month
it looks like her life coaching career
is working out about as well as her
marriage
and it also looks like there's nothing
left to say about amanda or to her
except you're cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
today on the ben shapiro show someone
leaks a draft of the supreme court
decision on roe versus wade and
apparently a majority is now ready to
end the non-existent constitutional
right to abortion and of course the left
goes absolutely completely insane and
bizarre that's today on the bench people
give it a listen